boeing says it will try to rebuild trust
in its planes with a new chief executive
the world's largest aerospace company
announced the firing of embattled CEO
dennis Muhlenberg yesterday in a
statement boeing calls the move
necessary to restore confidence and
promised full transparency
maaaan berg was under pressure for
months over his handling of a crisis
caused by two 737 max plane crashes Kris
Van Cleave has covered the Boeing story
throughout this rocky year after two 737
max crash has killed 346 people in five
months Boeing CEO Dennis Muhlenberg said
he was committed to fixing the problem
we know there are some improvements that
we can make regulators grounded the Macs
in March and Muhlenberg promised an
aggressive timeline to get the plane
back in the air during his exclusive May
interview with CBS Evening News anchor
and managing editor Norah O'Donnell do
you think the 737 max will be up in the
air by the end of the year I do and and
we're working very actively on that as I
said it's top priority for my company
instead the company was forced to
suspend production after the FAA said
Boeing's 2019 timeline was unrealistic
you've not told us the whole truth and
these families are suffering because of
it under pressure from frustrated
lawmakers and heartbroken families to
step aside Muhlenberg repeatedly
insisted he was the right person to lead
the company where he started as an
intern have you submitted or offered
your letter of resignation to your board
of directors congressman I have not I
don't see running away from a challenge
resigning as is the right solution
Michael Stu Moe who lost his daughter in
the Ethiopian crash welcomed Muhlenberg
forced resignation as a first step we
need people in there that know how to
make Boeing a great company that doesn't
kill people so they could survive the
next hundred years by resigning
Muhlenberg is likely walking away from
Boeing with an exit package worth tens
of millions of dollars
his replacement current board chairman
David Calhoun will take over in January
and one of his principal missions will
be restoring trust in Boeing for CBS
this morning Kris Van Cleave Mesa
Arizona
you